okay first things first titanfall 2
already seen it that was probably like
of the footage they showed a look of the
actual gameplay that we saw during that
press conference that was probably my
favorite I mean it was also arguably the
deepest look at any of the games that
they were showing off in Star Wars it
gotta roll everything together but
titanfall it's like all right here's two
separate trailers one for multiplayer
one for the single-player campaign which
we knew about but now hey it's official
we got this big trailer we got the kind
of creepy AI voiceover and the sort of
hinging at this relationship between
pilots and mechs we had speculated on
but now it's really confirmed it was
nice to see it in action yes the one
thing that looks great i mean lets you
can see how like a couple of years as
well as really given this engine a bit
of a bit of breathing room but i like
even like that transitioning at the
titans that are already on the field
instead of pretending like they're just
really learning a lot like I mean
obviously race one's a team that's
proved themselves to be quite reliable
but they also seem to be massively
listening to what their fans want and
something like that yes little bear was
like the big ask last year this gameplay
looks great it looks like the good Co
operating a lot of sweet mechanic yeah
from overwatch change up the yeah
there's tracers days old they are going
a lot of those like sort of added
mechanics that are layered on top of the
typical first person shooter looking
stuff sorry we're saying I would say
yeah yeah okay um yeah I just I think it
looks sweet I mean that they look like
they're you know delivering on the
grappling and everything like that like
they've already got mobility down as
such a central theme of what titanfall
is and it just seems like they're just
expanding on that so it's like
everything is faster everything is
parkour and movement and skill based and
I don't know I think I think they got it
down I think they're on the right track
it's going to be testing what to do with
the single-player campaign because
obviously in the multiplayer like
titanfall is based on his foundation of
you being able to move better and shoot
better than everyone else interested in
the single-player aspect of that at all
scott i'm happy to exist yeah I was
definitely with the course of people
saying where's the single player I mean
that's definitely how I like to play
games and I think that there was you
know a lot of lore simmering under the
surface in the first time that you just
kind of you you could tell was there but
wasn't
you weren't really able to explore it
given that was a multiplayer only game
so I'm excited that they're going to be
able to really lean into that stuff and
give us more insight in the universe and
it seems like it's going to lend itself
well to a single player experience so
I'm excited to see what they do with it
yeah coming real soon October 28 on pc
ps4 and xbox one